All white people are racist!
Each and every one of them! (No? You are.)
♫  Ano kousaten de  ♫
( What if everyone skipped down )
♫  Min’na ga moshi SUKIPPU wo shite  ♫
( Along the city streets that run all throughout the town )
♫  Moshi ano machi no man’naka de  ♫
( Imagine if we met up in the city’s heart )
♫  Te wo tsunaide sora wo miagetara  ♫
( And one by one we held hands and looked up the sky )
♫ ( “PONPONPON” / Kyary Pamyu Pamyu ) ♫
Let's see how racist we are
Today we're gonna do a test
it's made, umm it's a legit test
…to see if you're racist
how many racism do you have
you can do the test as well to see I hope I have
zero racism I think I think I do at
least I think I do but at the same time
apparently fidget spinners are a
Apparently, fidget spinners are a white supre- *mispronounces* white supremacist symbol...
now so you know who knows this could go
This could go either way, who kno- who knows? *laughs*
Let's do this
which statement best describes you
I strongly prefer okay well I'm kidding
I'm kidding I like white and black
people equally I like to think that's
what I think at least please rate how
warm or cold you feel to warm the
following group very warm very warm so
far I feel like I'm doing pretty well in
getting what you want it is sometimes
necessary to use force against other
group well I mean yeah shit I feel like
I'm failing this god damn it only if
they use force as well okay an eye for
an eye am i right now okay great
no one group should discriminate one
group should dominate Society but this
is some heavy heavy ask questions
alright I haven't thought about enough
about this I feel like I wouldn't say
strongly agree but I feel like I
moderately agree with that sometimes
other groups must be kept in their place
okay well now strongly disagree with
that well then then again there's Isis
you know the way I don't know if I could
goddamn it
yeah fuck I can't I can't honestly say I
saw it
I slightly agree why am i filming this
we should strive to make incomes
strongly agree our country needs a
powerful leader in order to destroy the
radical and immoral currents prevailing
in society today I disagree I slightly
disagree I don't think a powerful leader
is necessary facts show that we have to
be harder against crime and sexual
immorality okay fine is it better to
accept bad literature than to censor it
strongly agree just because I don't
agree with it doesn't mean I should
censor it that one that one is the only
one I feel I can strongly actually put
myself behind the rest of these I might
want to adjust later okay
many good people challenge the state
criticize the church and ignore the
normal way of living many good people
ahh I agree it would be best if
newspaper were censored so that people
would not be able to get hold of
destructive in this strongly disagree
what the fuck
okay here we go in the next tax task you
will presented with a set of words okay
black people faces of black people white
people faces - white people again Oh
what put your okay okay oh god do I have
to guess who they are what the fuck is
this test I think black I think white I
think black I think white I think like I
think like god damn it oh my god this is
terrible why am I doing this white white
white white white up like wow fuck oh my
god did I do it see the evolved
academies have changed all you trying to
mind fuck of me we was good and bad okay
fix the error by hitting V okay all
right awful bad bad good
good bad this is so weird
oh my god
I'm so nervous okay I think I did good
wait what white people or black people
good or bad you they want me to be
racist
why aren't they putting white people
will then okay it's like they know it's
like they know some insecure white guys
sitting here like please I hope I'm not
racist I swear I'm not okay what black
people isn't it sort of racist to put
black people with bad
okay I think I'm doing okay good
black good good I mean wow no bad bad
good and white then I can't upload this
video
Oh
fuck I'm focused as fuck I don't want to
be racism
fuck this test man
how does he judge me from this I don't
understand
bad good ah ah God you see what he's
doing there in my head oh my god okay
notice above there are only two
categories and they have switched
positions okay oh my god so it's
opposite now okay okay easy not a
problem
I'm not racist white black black like
black that's the same image white black
uh yeah why
okay come on not racist white white
white white black white black Oh psych
hey or die I'm kidding I'm kidding
god damn it ah I'm not doing well okay
what I'm so nervous you guys yeah I'm
legit in there okay
okay so now white people are bad and
black people are good fuck this is my
fucking me
it's fucking mindful you get out of my
head I feel like thought police made
this game god damn it okay alright
this
Oh God
No
okay I'm this is easy because all I have
to do is think that why people are bad
fat bad bad bad
I'm literally going in my head why
people are bad why people are bad when
we were what now shit fuck I am so
nervous because I did not do very well I
saw my god
this is it this is the Wall Street
Journal what they wouldn't waiting for
I'm a male does that matter does that
matter - my racist I am all my stomach
hurts I'm so nervous
and my less racist if I'm from a
different place in the world what the
fuck am i okay that might pull it I
guess I'm neutral as you do they have a
youtuber here oh look they do no
religion not at all
I got a okay I got a graduate diploma in
engineering okay
Sweden oh my god come on Sweden come on
Sweden here we go my result okay why are
we still here
just suffer
every night I can feel my leg my arm
fuck god damn it, your data suggests a
moderate automatic preference for white people
I'm racist godammit *laughter* fuck
you don't know that, about me okay… listen you don't
goddamn it fuck wall street polygons
please shit uh it's just it's just a
test the interpretation is described as
automatic for white if you responded
faster when faces of white people and
good words were classified with the same
key then when faces of black people in
good words were classified that's so
stupid that doesn't even make any sense
well god damn it why did I do this why
did I think this was a good idea I'll
let you guys know in the comments I
really don't think I am actually racist
I know I can say that and this data is
telling me I offer sit but you try it
and see if you get I'm sure I'm sure
we're all racist
we're all racist a little bit okay
aren't we all racist it's okay I'm
trying to dig myself out I can't do it
help
leave a like for racist I mean fuck ah I
subtitles
spinners i guess they were left/right